I didn't know you were smoking so much
weed before school but only my senior
year junior year second semester junior
year my first semester there I got
straight A's yeah that's true that did
not last long is there anything looking
back you still think we made a bad
choice anything you can think about
where when you have kids you're like I'm
gonna do that a little differently
grounding me for a whole summer
well
do you really think that was a bad move
or you just didn't like it oh I just
hated it oh yeah then that doesn't count
I just disagree with it you said
disagree with that's what I disagree
with I disagree that I got grounded for
a whole summer do you disagree with it
because you think it was the wrong
choice or just because you didn't like
it
hey man everybody steals weed from their
parents at one time
everybody does not not everybody but
there's a certain there's a certain
couple I don't feel like I should have
gotten grounded for a whole summer so
why you got grounded for the whole
summer it wasn't the Vape no did you get
grounded for stealing my weed yes oh you
should have been yeah I worked hard for
that I'm fine for a little bit not the
whole [__] summer man like that was
my summer before my senior year yeah
yeah yeah we didn't let you outside huh
just the backyard or my phone
I didn't have my phone at all that
summer either yeah dude you're lucky you
had anything yeah you know what I used
to do when you guys went to bed though I
used to go into the living room remember
that old desk we had in the living room
that was just in the right that random
Corner that was my grandfather's desk
yeah your mom always put her iPad in
there so when you guys went to bed I
would go out of my room I would grab the
iPad I would bring it into my room and I
would log into all of my social media
things that I remember passwords for and
also if I turn on the Wi-Fi on the iPad
it just acted as I could text people so
I would text my girlfriend until I went
to sleep and then before I went to bed I
would turn I would log myself out of all
those apps and then bring the iPad back
into the the desk put it there and then
sneaky back
yeah so what happens when technology is
present at respect that I respect the
Ingenuity oh and also I would I I before
you guys took my phone away I remember
or not memorized but I wrote down all of
my friends phone numbers
and so that I could text them but then
also like I would call them on the home
phone
oh we still had a home phone yeah you
guys had a landline until I was like 20.
yeah your mom like we used to have a
landline now why your mom likes landline
dude just in case [__] goes down
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]